who will be the next british prime
minister rishi sunak and liz trust are
the final two candidates to replace
boris johnson as leader of the
conservative party so what's their
vision for the uk and its relationship
with the rest of the world this is
inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now britain will either
have its third female prime minister or
its first with south asian heritage liz
trust and rishi sunak won the most votes
from conservative mps to take over from
boris johnson who is stepping down now
after a series of scandals the decision
now rests with around 160 000 party
members they have just over a month now
to choose between trust the foreign
secretary and sunak who is a former
chancellor of the exchequer now both say
they have what it takes to tackle record
high inflation boost the economy and win
the next election jonah hull reports
therefore rishi sooner
and liz truss
will be the candidates going forward
conservative party mps have spoken now
grassroots members will decide whether
former chancellor rishi sunak or foreign
secretary liz truss should go on to be
party leader and britain's next prime
minister
both are divisive characters both have
the experience of high office
trust promises what she calls a truly
conservative economic agenda tax cuts
and a hike in defense spending i'm the
person who can go into number 10 i can
hit the ground running and i can get
things done
sunak says he'll stabilize the economy
ease the cost of living crisis and win
the next election the question now for
our members is who is the best person to
defeat kirstar in the labour party at
the next election i believe i'm the only
candidate who can do that
and there's a further distinction
between the two while liz truss is seen
as the candidate most likely to continue
boris johnson's brand of populist
politics rishi sunak isn't popular in
downing street where he's seen as having
betrayed johnson earning him the
distrust of party members a poll of
those very party members who will elect
the next prime minister suggests that
liz truss is far more likely to win
than rishi sunak
before the focus shifted to a very
public summer leadership campaign there
was time for parliament to say goodbye
to boris johnson at his final session at
the dispatch box in prime minister's
questions i do know that the
relationship between a prime minister
and leader of the opposition
is never easy
and this one's proved no exception to
the rule
but i would like to take this
opportunity to wish him his wife and his
family the best for the future
johnson had this advice for his
successor number one stay close to the
americans stick up for the ukrainians
stick up for freedom and democracy
everywhere
johnson's relatively short tenure
included he said restoring the uk's
independence from europe and battling
the pandemic but then a string of
scandals brought his office into
disrepute
mr speaker i want to thank everybody
here and
hasta la vista
baby
johnson exited the house of commons to
rousing applause the next prime minister
will be named on september the 5th jonah
al jazeera london
well let's now bring in our guests in
london we have mo hussein he's a
political commentator and also a former
special adviser to the uk home office
in dundee scotland leslie riddock a
journalist and the director of the
nordic horizons think tank and also in
london is jonathan liss deputy director
of the think tank british influence a
warm welcome to you all and thank you
for joining us on inside story now i
want to start by taking a bit of a
closer look at the two candidates
because they're very similar in some
ways vastly different in others now i
believe both of them went to oxford both
of them studied philosophy politics and
economics as many in british government
seem to have done now they are both
perceived as tory elite but sunak i see
despite being one of the richest men in
britain has been trying to paint the
story of himself as as a british success
story the son of immigrants someone who
worked as a waster in the local indian
restaurant when he was a teenager mo i'm
curious how is that narrative played
within the party i think it's played
relatively well uh people do like a good
back story and there's been other
candidates who have made a really big
thing about their family background the
values that they had growing up and the
fact that
they perhaps weren't from the uk but
they came here and they have risen to a
really high office uh in government and
high ranking roles in the conservative
party so i think people do like that but
as long as then that is made use of and
can be translated into leadership and
what you would do when you actually then
become the prime minister
and the opportunities you would give to
other people so i think it serves a
purpose but it does need to then uh
translate into action as well of course
there has in the meantime though been
some controversy i believe over his
heiress wife's tax status especially as
they have what a combined fortune of
730 million pounds that certainly hasn't
helped perceptions of him being rich and
out of touch leslie how much has that
hurt him
well i think it has hurt enormously and
it depends which people you're referring
to here in judgement terms because
there's the wider public who might have
one view of both the candidates and
indeed the whole
quite vicious tory leadership campaign
but then the people who really matter
are that 200 000 tory membership who are
really quite atypical of the whole
population but still um on social media
for example over the last couple of days
um there's been not big discussions
about the debates on tax but the
observation that rishi sudart went to a
building site somewhere wearing prada
shoes
why this should matter who knows but
it's always just picking away at that
point that he earns so much another way
of putting it as you've just done is
that he actually earns more than the
queen now to a lot of people who value
the monarchy that just kind of feels
wrong so this will he will always be on
the back foot on that one no matter how
often he gets his supporters to come in
and talk endlessly about his life his
young life uh living on top of a chemist
pharmacy
sure speaking of his young life in his
life now he would be the first prime
minister british prime minister of color
if he wins as we've been saying now i
know he says his heritage is enormously
important to him he talks about during
his childhood going to temple one day
and then southampton football matches
the next i know he's also spoken about
how britain he feels has become more
open and more integrated jonathan do you
think race and ethnicity will play any
kind of a role in the vote here the vote
within the tory party itself
i think we need to acknowledge that
there are some people perhaps in the
touring membership who might be less
inclined to vote for sunak on account of
race but i think the majority of
conservatives actually would be happy to
vote for him i think the key point to
make here is that provided the
candidates are singing from the same
anti-immigration hymn sheet which they
all are then it won't actually matter
the fundamental disconnect is that
richie sunaik made a great play about
how his family uh have came from
somewhere else in his campaign video but
like all the other candidates he is
promising to deport um migrants who've
come here across the channel and
refugees to rwanda a policy which would
have seemed completely extreme a few
months ago and is now mainstream in the
conservative party so i think that you
know until the conservative party thinks
about what it really really wants to do
about immigration and multiculturalism
it doesn't actually matter the skin
color of the people who are conveying
that message sure i want to talk briefly
here about brexit because both
candidates did have different approaches
so sunak he was a brexiteer he said he
voted for a campaign for leave as well
because he wanted to shake things up a
bit and then create space for change and
trust though notably voted remain
and then has since changed her mind
mo do you think that hurts her and
especially this idea that she could
change her mind on big ticket policies
in the future
well it goes back to the point about who
the audience is so the membership is uh
heavily
brexit supporting so i think
liz trust has said that she regrets her
decision and i think that is aimed at
just reassuring them that she does see
the benefits of brexit and she will work
to deliver that but i don't think it
hurts her
too much uh because we've come to a
point where uh you know this argument
was quite prevalent in the 2019 election
i think it's less so now there are
clearly uh progress that does need to be
made and issues need to be resolved on
the northern ireland protocol but the
real uh issue facing the uk at the
moment is the cost of living in the
economy and i think that uh surpasses
other issues uh and it just feels that
the brexit argument is slightly aged and
yes she did quite remain
since then she has
re-calibrated herself let's say into a
brexiteer
and i think she's probably now more
known for that than to remain a few
years ago well one of the big issues for
british voters who aren't in the south
and who are in scotland has been this
idea of scottish independence and
they've also reacted very strongly to
what happened with brexit
now i understand liz spent part of her
childhood in scotland so leslie i'm
wondering then how is she viewed there
particularly around this issue of
potential scottish independence
well all the tory candidates have had a
very sort of solid line
of saying that no matter what mandate is
given to the scottish government
repeatedly to hold a second independence
referendum in light of that brexit vote
which is the change in circumstance that
that means essentially the first vote
was
held in false pretenses in many respects
um they all hold the same line which is
just no many commentators think that
just keep saying no to a democratic
process won't hold for long but it's the
position they all share as far as her
background's concerned it's not really
doing her a lot of good it's more that
the scots just keep voting not tory and
they have done we have done for the best
part of a hundred years with a small
exception in the 1950s so whoever is the
product of a tory leadership
contest will not really go down very
well here just one other wee thing about
that uh she talked when she was picked
on by rishi sunak in the debates um and
he'd asked her do you regret moore being
a remain supporter
or a member of the liberal lib dems
she rounded on him and started to talk
about her background uh in in scotland
and saying how she'd become a
conservative because she was so appalled
by the low standard of education that
she'd seen around her will that
education for her was spent entirely
during the period margaret thatcher was
prime minister so it hasn't taken people
very long here to look at that and think
well what are you actually saying a lot
of what she says seems very
contradictory and seems thought of in
this in the heat of the moment
and doesn't really seem to hold water
the next moment
well it's interesting you mentioned that
she was a member of the liberal
democrats because she was raised in a
household by parents who as she
describes it in her own words had
left-leaning politics i believe she even
protested for nuclear disarmament she
was even a republican and made
statements to that effect when she was a
teenager
has she mowed you think actually managed
to convince tory is that she's tory
through and through enough yeah i think
she has um
internal polling that the party has will
show that she's very very popular with
the members i've been to many
conservative party conferences and the
queues for her events where she's
speaking are much larger than anybody
else's so there is something about her
that does resonate
with the members and you know part of
part of that is the reinvention and it's
about
being on a journey as she said that she
was on but it's about what matters to
people now and what solutions she can
provide so i do think that uh members
will be looking at her
what she's saying and what she's doing
in the next six weeks or so rather than
what she did when she was a teenager
sure well speaking of timely solutions
she's also obviously foreign secretary
at a rather sensitive and tumultuous
time for britain and and the rest of the
world
does the war in ukraine do you think
jonathan help her case because
it gives a perception of her perhaps as
a more steady hand there has been a lot
of criticism of her being a lightweight
so to speak frankly
i don't think the ukraine war is going
to have much
impact on the debate and i have to say
that
it's much easier to be a war leader when
you're not actually fighting a war the
same can be said at boris johnson all
that the conservative government needs
to do
was to pledge assistance to kiev to send
arms and they did that and they
admittedly did that better and faster
than some other countries but it was not
some sort of staggering fleet um that
was achieved in london and i think that
any conservative leader and foreign
secretary would have done the same any
future conservative leader uh will do
the same as well i think liz trust is
desperate to kind of harness her it's a
pro-ukraine pro-brexit credentials but
it does feel a little bit desperate and
it also might backfire in the case of
brexit and our relations with the world
because let's not forget that as foreign
secretary she's actually
threatened to break international law
with her ability to uh overturn the
northern ireland protocol which is a
centerpiece of the treaty britain signed
with the eu now if uh trust or student
app for that matter uh if they go
through with that as prime minister
because the bill is still going through
parliament then that will invite a
full-scale trade war with the eu
in a cost of living crisis that will be
a catastrophe for britain's economy and
neither of the candidates is prepared to
admit that or say what they're going to
do about it i see you're agreeing there
leslie how is this being perceived in
parts of the uk outside of england do
you think given the potential risks that
it has for britain as a whole
well i think really people probably
across the whole united kingdom who are
out with that small tiny tiny band of
people who have some say in this uh
leadership contest are just sitting back
somewhat bemused a little bit aghast
depending on their politics and
realizing that this huge decision about
the shape of britain to come
is completely out of their hands because
there will not be another general
election quickly since it's pretty
evident that very probably the
conservatives would lose it so we see
this big reshaping happening and
sometimes we're told that there's a
great need for change all the candidates
are saying that despite the fact that
the conservatives have been in charge
for the last 12 years so change from
what their own policies
or else we get the message that it's all
about continuity and uh it's it's a very
puzzling thing because if there has been
a big change since 2019 then that
manifesto that elected boris johnson
really doesn't hold anymore you know if
you were really thinking about democracy
you might think that needed to have a
fresh mandate so really i think a lot of
people are just sitting watching the
machinations the mechanisms and all of
this churn going on
as if it is a bit of a pantomime but
such an important one when we've got
everything to to figure out including
adjustments to take account of the
massive heat that we've just experienced
in britain that shows that the climate
crisis should be really top of our
thinking there's nobody running
government until september the 5th
well as we watch that process take place
right now i want to look a little more
at their chances
mo we know that liz trust as you've been
saying is the current favorites
but
rishi sunak won more consistent support
from mps in all the votes that we saw so
why is that
well because i think
he as a chancellor has had quite a lot
to do with backbench mps when you're
going through things like uh financial
statements with a budget you will engage
with mps you will ask them what kind of
things they are looking for uh in their
constituencies and you'll build up uh
patronage and you'll build up support
and i think he's been very good at
doing that um and i think the mps again
are different audience to the membership
the mps will be looking at very much
more being in the chamber with him
seeing how he performs each week who is
the person who can take the fight to the
opposition who is the person who can uh
help win the next election and mps will
have to go and sell
him to their members as well and
there'll be lots of hustings around the
country and then you know members will
then look at what did mp think and then
also their own views and they will be
swayed by who is the best potential of
winning the next election because it's
fine that people are making all these
promises saying i'll reduce your taxes
i'll do this i'll do that but if you're
not in government you can't do any of it
so it's also in the members interest to
elect somebody who can win the next
election of course well this seems like
a good time to take a look at just who
will be actually casting ballots ahead
of that september 5th announcement well
there are between 160 000 and 200 000
conservative party members now research
from 2018 suggests that more than half
are older than 60 97 of them are white
71 percent are men
and more than half of them live in
london and the south of england
traditionally the richest parts of the
uk
so jonathan let me pose this question to
you these mostly elderly mostly white
mostly men
seem to be more likely to prefer trust
why
because of their politics
she's seen as ironically more of a true
believer on brexit perhaps that's the
zeal of the convert as we said she voted
to remain in 2016.
also she's pledging radical tax cuts uh
which
make her seem more conservative than
rishi sunak
and as we know uh memberships of parties
often pitch to the extremes and that's
not where uh the voters might be in the
country either conservative votes or
voters more generally but that's where
elections are often won and that's why
membership votes are not always helpful
for a party because the membership might
elect someone they want but who doesn't
have the wide appeal in the country that
that party will need to win an election
and i don't think that either trust or
cena is going to be particularly
electable against labor the trust even
less so than sooner well let me ask that
question then about broad-based support
because that is really the key question
right who will be able to get the tories
back into power in the next election
which i believe is due in january 2025
if an early election isn't called now do
you think leslie that either of these
candidates would be able to rally the
kind of support that we saw that johnson
was able to do especially amongst
usually labor voters especially in the
north of england well no in a word i
mean not neither of them has whatever
charisma boris johnson seems to be able
to exercise on people it would have to
be said not in scotland where he's
always been a vote loser but that sort
of bumps um
boisterous
boosterism that boris has brought with
him to everything and his ability to
really
black white white black deny every
difficulty that he's found himself in
with the the eloquence of someone you
know to the manor born
all of that comes with boris right
neither of the other two are quite that
fluent or charming
this trust i would think must be quite
an alarming prospect for mps because she
she doesn't really perform very well in
debates and we've seen that that's
partly why the debates were scrapped but
um if if the if there's a business of
being challenged by kierstarmer at the
dispatch box in the house of commons
week after week
listtrust seems to me to be someone
who's likely to come on stock quite
badly now whether that matters it's hard
to know completely because clearly a lot
of tory supporters will stick with her
because of her politics and
her channeling of margaret thatcher
which seems to be her main claim to fame
but i think that's going to be a big
problem if she goes ahead if rishi sunat
goes ahead well there's keir starmer
another professional former director of
public prosecutions a lawyer there's two
slightly standoffish characters who
neither of whom have that old-fashioned
bounce that boris brought to proceedings
so it's it's all there for the for for
for the competitions if those two go
ahead well i i want to talk very briefly
about thatcher because rishi sunak says
he plans to put into place staturite
economic policies and that is where the
battleground seems to lie but margaret
thatcher is also as you suggested
they're an icon for liz trust you even i
believe played the role of thatcher in
her school play in primary school so mo
as a member of the conservative party
yourself how would you differentiate
their policies
well
it feels like the focus at the moment
and it's quite fashionable now to talk
about tax cuts from the economy
partially because tax cuts is one thing
you can do quite quickly when you have
two years or less towards the next
general election but i think the
difference is that rishi tsunak is
trying to be a bit more realistic than
people uh by saying
if you want uh
better more investment in the country
that has been promised was promised by
boris johnson in 2019 as part of the
so-called leveling up agenda uh
improving conditions in the north and
the midlands if you want better public
services these have to be paid for by
uh something you can't just be based on
borrowing so
and with the state of inflation in the
uk tax cuts at some point but not right
now which is very different to what liz
trust and in fact most of the other
candidates who have now been knocked out
were saying in terms of promising the
tax cuts straight away so i think that
will be the big dividing line the other
dividing lines we will see in the next
few weeks but we have to remember that
these two people were probably two of
the most senior people in the boris
johnson government and they as much as
they are now trying to draw a bit of
distance between themselves and him they
were
part of uh what we saw happen in terms
of perhaps not standing up to him or not
challenging him early enough so looking
for the dividing lines will be
interesting because at the moment it's
not really where they're going to come
from well i do want to finish up with a
very quick straw poll here of
predictions and we'll obviously be
holding you tightly to your pick here um
so liz truss or richie sunak who's going
to be the new pm jonathan you go first
trust or sunac at the moment trust is a
favorite but i think that once the two
of them start speaking in the debates
um tory members will will start fearing
trust and might just go for sunak but i
don't think the sunac will be
particularly electable in the whole
because uh because because i just think
that he has a big personal uh
presentation problem and big personal
baggage as well with voices leslie
trust will sooner very well i've already
got a five i've got a five pound bet on
rishi sunak which um which i'm so i'm
just going to hang in there with that
one and mo
i'm going towards rishi as well
yes he does have some issues but also he
is known for
having helped a lot of people in the
pandemic and spending lots of money to
do so and i think people will remember
that as well going forward in terms of
how creative and how versatile it can be
well we'll see how right you all are in
the coming weeks thank you to all of our
guests mo hussein leslie riddock and
jonathan lisz and thank you too for
watching you can see this program again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story for me nostalgia and the whole
team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you